good day everyone and welcome i'm jack van horn
from the university of virginia and i am proud
to welcome you to this edition of our 2021 2022
foundations of biomedical data science seminar
series this lecture series is supported by uva's
integrated translational health institute of
virginia the uva brain institute the college of
arts and sciences the school of data science and
through a grant from the national institutes of
general medical sciences our theme for this year
is ethical challenges of artificial intelligence
in biomedicine where we enjoy presentations
on fridays from leading thinkers about the
promise opportunities and hurdles associated
with ai applications in the biomedical sciences
selected participants in our biomedical data
science innovation lab program will leverage these
presentations as vital material for a culminating
in-person grant project development workshop to be
held here in historic charlottesville virginia in
june today i am delighted to welcome our speaker
sean valles from michigan state university where
i learned today that he has been for 11 years and
he is an associate professor and the director of
the michigan state university center for bioethics
and social justice he earned his bachelor of arts
in 2005 from st john's college and m.a from
indiana university in bloomington in 2008
and his phd at indiana university at bloomington
in 2010. he is a philosopher of health focusing on
evidentiary and ethical complexities of how social
context shapes health he is the author of the 2018
book philosophy of population health
philosophy for a new public health era
that he was also had a co sorry he is also
a co-editor with quill kukla of the oxford
university book series bioethics for social
justice in continuing our 2021-2022 biomedical
data science seminar series theme sean's lecture
today is entitled interdisciplinarity in the
health sciences and the pursuit of health equity
in sean's presentation today he will remind us
that health equity has been one of the what
most widely endorsed goals of health science
research at the same time interdisciplinarity
has been widely endorsed as a means of enriching
health science research but sean will point out
that the relationships between these two proposals
is not always that clear his presentation will
describe how the interdisciplinarity framework
of population health science offers a
coherent account of how interdisciplinary can
interdisciplinarity can directly serve the
goals of health equity with humanity and
humility serving as the key connecting concept
as always we are streaming this lecture live and
for recording via youtube if you are watching via
youtube thank you so much for joining us today and
also our specially selected 2021 2022 biomedical
data science innovation lab participants
are strongly encouraged to submit any questions
for sean valles this chat feature in their zoom
sessions i will synthesize these questions and
i will ask them during the discussion period uh
of our presentation today last 10 minutes or so
of the hour and with that sean welcome and thank
you so much for providing us with your thoughts
and your vision and your experience we've been
really looking forward to your lecture thank you
very much for the opportunity to be here i um
it's uh it's wonderful to be invited
it's a it's a it's of course an honor
and um uh i really appreciate how uh how amazingly
well organized this whole this whole show is um
it's uh it's been a pleasure working with
uh with the folks behind the scene here
um and so um so so thank you for uh for making
this um not only possible but also easy um it
seems like nothing is easy now um so uh yeah
the uh i guess the sort of the the snapshot
view of this has already been given so i
think i will jump right into this on this
relationship between interdisciplinarity
and health equity in the health sciences
so uh i'm going to sort of give you two sides of a
coin so on the one hand for an individual patient
their risk for heart disease for cancer for
innumerable other sort of health outcomes
is going to be attributable to a bunch of
different factors often interacting and a
lot of those are going to be genetic or congenital
or or otherwise sort of hard to um hard to change
for the individual you can sort of deal with the
you can deal with the hand you got dealt to you by
by life um but it's very hard short of things like
like gene therapy which are sort of coming onto
the horizon to actually change some of those some
of those things to actually change the hand that
you were given um and in that same vein clinical
medicine has made such a some really amazing
advances towards doing things like improving
um i've just as an example here some uh cancer
death rates they sort of been going up for for
for many many many years and then in the 1990s
they started actually declining um which is really
amazing it's an amazing accomplishment in the in
the arena of sort of dealing with those individual
risk factors especially um so uh and this is this
is historically sort of where i where i did a lot
of my sort of early early work with sort of like
looking at these like what are these sort of risk
factors how do we think about them that kind of
stuff i i have a doctoral minor in genetics um
and so i was working on sort of like um how we
sort of conceptualize genetic evidence and medical
genetics so that's on one hand on the other hand
there are massive between population
differences that are pretty obviously
not genetic or congenital or otherwise sort of
um it's just the way that or an unchangeable or
very difficult to change aspect of the hand you're
adults so um so as an example this is a i thought
i would sort of use the university of virginia you
know i'm not sure where people are geographically
but you know um this is a super high resolution
look at local life expectancy patterns using
data from up through 2015 um there's often a
wagon with this kind of stuff and so um this
kind of this kind of granularity of data isn't
available to almost anywhere in the world the uss
is relatively sophisticated with our
data collection on this kind of thing
and so these are basically at birth like what's
your life expectancy if you live in this little
micro neighborhood um it's actually using uh
census designated areas so what i did here
is i cross referenced those those years in that
map with the life expectancies of countries that
have they have almost have identical or nearly
identical life expectancies to give you a sense of
the way in which we can we can be living
geographically next to somebody or to
or next to a population and in some sense we're
also living worlds apart um or at least in terms
of this the scale of the differences so so for
instance i grew up uh sort of like on the edge
of a health cliff in um in uh partially in um in
sort of suburban boston and if i if i traveled
two blocks east of me then i would uh uh the life
expectancy would go down on just shy of 11 years
and so that's that's actually not a typical
and so you know you have sections around the
university of virginia where people are living
um 87.1 years which is higher than the highest
of of life expectancies for any country and you
know just a few miles away of people living um
less than 74 years so this is sort of the
scale of differences that were that we're
sort of talking about because i i do this in a
lot of my talks because i think there's there's a
it's easy to underestimate how big of
the differences i'm talking about here
um uh it's or it's uh or to also get a sense of um
some of the international scope um the us is a is
an outlier among among high income nations where
we have um our life expectancy chronic disease
rate sort of like almost every health measure
we're sort of we're we're well behind or very very
very far behind most other wealthy nations and so
uh our life expectancy peaked in 2014 we've never
made it to 79 years as a country on average um
and for instance spain got there in the year 2000
um i it's something i sort of i can
sometimes press on maybe even a little
too hard when i'm talking to folks who are
working inside um inside biomedical sciences
because i think the um there is uh it's easy to
assume that that more technology will sort of sort
of buy us more health um and often it can in some
ways like you know those those declining uh those
declining cancer mortality rates a lot of that has
to do with the the um basically the kind of nih
centered work that y'all are doing but at the same
time you know spain was able to to get better and
was able to achieve our highest level at the same
time as the as the invention of the of the ipod um
let alone the iphone like way before that
so um so this is kind of so i want to sort
of uh i want to point out this this is sort of
like the scope of what we're talking about here
in terms of between population differences
so we're talking about equity there's nothing
about this that's okay i can't imagine an
ethical system under which it is cool that
there is this these enormous enormous enormous
differences between populations that have really
no justification or reason that i can see it it
doesn't have to be this way i'll come back to that
so um so one way of sort of cashing out
this difference is um what uh with the
epidemiologist and sort of population health
thinker prevention preventive medicine thinker
jeffrey rose said is the difference between
the causes of cases and the causes of incidents
um so this is something that um again i'll sort
of i'll deal i'll delve further into this and
talking about um population health theory um in
just a little bit but um there there are just
basically two different types of causes and
effects we can sort of look at in the world
so it's um so one way of sort of talking
about this distinction between the causes
of causes of cases versus causes of incidence
is take something like u.s heart disease risks
so the causes of an individual person getting
heart disease or not are attributable to a huge
number of different things and a lot of them are
going to be genetic factors or other congenital
factors like like developmental developmental
patterns that you're sort of just born with and
so my family so personally my family history my
genetic my genetic lineage all that kind of stuff
that all comes into play my likelihood of having
a heart attack or not in the next 10 years so so
the so the difference between whether i get a case
of heart disease or if the person next to me does
those differences are going to be to a large
extent um genetic unchangeable that kind of thing
at the same time there are massive
differences between on between on average
heart disease um heart disease outcomes for black
americans and for white americans and also for
also for hispanic americans like me and so
the the thing is though there are these big
differences between populations between black
americans and white americans for instance there's
a massive amount of research on that and there are
differences between individuals the thing that
people sometimes misum mistake is assuming that
it's for the same reasons and so the difference
these differences between me and another person
and our arts uh another person standing next to
me our differences in heart disease risk might be
might be due largely or even predominantly to
to genetic factors but when there's when there's
actually been focused research looking at are any
of the known genetic factors that cause that that
are known to be they're known to have played a
causal role in heart disease risks or any of those
accounting for those between race differences
and uh kaufman that all have some as really cool
research they did in 2015 this has been backed up
in a million other studies in a million other ways
that no there is no overlap and so we have between
population disparities we have between individual
disparities and they're just not they're not
attributable to the same stuff so we have um
so we have this really annoying problem that we
need to sort of ask different questions about
why is this patient getting sick as opposed
to why is this population getting sick
um and so they are they are both important
questions but they are not the same question
so what we're left with in
the case of something like
like like racial health disparities or
i sometimes i i really prefer to use the
term racist health disparities for for the
reasons i'm about to lay out a moment um
it's almost always going to be that these outcomes
that we're worried about and so um so so going
back to health equity that they're attributable
to a racist racial climate structured around race
concepts not because of actual genetic differences
between um racially identified populations and so
if you want to talk afterwards about like what is
the what is sort of the state of knowledge about
but average differences between different
populations and their their genetic
makeup or whatever the short version is no races
are not biological concepts this will hold up
according to modern science they were they
were racist 18th or 17th century concepts
that sort of stuck around for a long time and we
we sort of will these differences into existence
and so you have massive massive effects like um
that american indian and alaska natives um native
populations with um this is uh even before the
pandemic where things got weirder um uh uh 5.5
years on average less than the u.s average
that's a massive difference and then people
will sometimes say like oh there's that thing but
aren't there also differences between isn't sickle
cell anemia partially racially patterned or isn't
this stuff about lactose tolerance and different
genetic diseases and there's some interesting
data on asthma rates somehow being attributed
partially to partially related to um to ancestry
like yeah yes probably some of that is true but um
it's really important to recognize that those
are essentially going to be rounding errors
within a massive massive massive uh exception
where you have huge huge differences
and based on everything we know about any possible
genetic factors that would be contributing to that
it's going to be at most a rounding error and
some of that might not even hold up over time
so so when i talk about um a society structured
by racism or it's or uh um or other sort of
formulations of white of that um the kind of
framework i wanna i wanna sort of propose to
people for sort of thinking about the range of
ways that we sort of think about the um the causal
structure of the problem of racially inequitable
health outcomes um this one comes from kamara
kumara phyllis jones who is the former president
of the american public health association and she
divides it into into sort of three different um
sort of like zones and so you can have a racial
climate a racist racial climate that negatively
impacts health outcomes through three different
sort of uh three different modalities so you have
personally mediated which is sort of the one that
people sort of talk about the most when they talk
about racism is sort of interpersonal relations
in one way or another and so you can have a doctor
treat their black patients differently in a way
that is negatively impacting them and so there's
all sorts of research on the way that that happens
it's horrible and i try to deal with that as
someone who works inside of medical school
we can also lead to things where um uh there's
a is a big new branch of research right now on
on the role of stress response and so um uh
there's what's called the weathering hypothesis
that seems to have held up pretty well so far
which essentially says that the um these the
chronic stresses of of interpersonal racism or
even just the experience of sort of having having
all eyes on you when you walk into a store people
walking just watching to see if you're going to be
expecting you're going to be shoplifting um
this sort of this this negative sense of being
sort of discriminated against and sort of being
scrutinized negatively really takes a takes a
physical toll on the body that can be measured
and so it's um it wears you down um and uh it
causes elevated stress stress hormones that take
that basically takes wear and tear on your body
and it causes negative health outcomes so
so there's a lot of different so it can be
sort of like just negative negative treatment
interpersonally and sort of like the obvious
way but it can also be sort of the uh the
accumulated effects of other people sort
of like having these little microaggressions
and negative negative impacts on you over time
um there's also institutionalized racism um
which is something that we are sort of like
gradually starting to talk about more as a country
which like good um so things like differences in
socioeconomic status i'll i can sort of
address a little bit more of that later
access to health care there are big gaps
in terms of average wealth average access
to health care i can sort of get get into the
numbers but it's uh it's really quite horrifying
and at the same time there's also um there's
also the phenomenon of internalized racism
which is something that's that um it makes a
lot of people uncomfortable to talk about um
but it can it can do things like um basically
people from from marginalized populations like
let's all take the example of mia so i'm i'm a
chicano hispanic mexican-american um and so so
there so there are people in my community who are
sort of like who become sort of nihilistic about
about their um about their health prospects and
so you sort of learn to to to accept the the law
that you've been given by life and so it's like oh
well well um people like us we just get diabetes
and there's nothing we can really do about that
um it's uh it's just sort of like it's a it's
a certain fatalism about it and it ends up with
the same sort of negative impact as if you have
schools set up to sort of very very subtly tell
to um tell girls as they're growing up that girls
don't do well in math then they start sort of
playing a social role of not doing as well in math
and so it's the same kind of it's the same
kind of thing where you start internalizing
these negative messages because it's the world
is sort of like telling you these messages again
and again and again and eventually people start
to believe in that's that's really horrifying
so all three of these simultaneously and
sometimes interacting will lead to negative
health outcomes and so that's a lot of
different mediums of of negative impact
and at the same time um so it's not just not
just in terms of wealth there's also there's also
what's called the wealth health gradient um this
is the this is the graph i think about every year
when it comes time to to find out whether i'm
going to get a raise or not so this is a graph of
life expectancy again life expectancy is a it's a
it's a good sort of shorthand for looking at sort
of like overall health outcomes um based on your
percentile of income and so for every percentile
of income that you go up so does generally your
your odds of living another year um so this is
this is a life expectancy for 40 year olds and
so um so i'll be turning 40 in a matter of months
and i'm sure wondering like where am i going to
end up on this on this graph when i get there
like if i get that raise maybe i'll be farther on
this end than on this end and i would like to see
my daughter grew up and things
like that and so it's um
uh the the the point here is that um other
countries have have gradings like this too
the us is relatively unique in having ours
is really steep um this is these are really
big differences between just like a single
percentile of income so the the one percent and uh
and the very very bottom percent are
are in very vastly different experiences
so so what's the what's sort of the theoretical
takeaway that some people have been getting
from this well the idea is that very broadly
and there are different sort of theoretical
lenses for looking at this is this idea that
we that that effectively promoting health
trying to make it better is going to require
action across the whole of society so if if our
if our racial health disparities are as a result
of socioeconomic status and also interpersonal
relations inside the clinic and also the the
accumulated stresses of living inside living
inside neighborhoods where you're being negatively
scrutinized and also it's the the sort of like the
the the insidious development of negative views
about one's own body and one's own behavior
if it's all of that kind of stuff just just in
the example of racial health outcomes then what
we need is we we need action across the entirety
of society to deal with this kind of stuff and so
this sometimes goes under the under the label of
health in all policies which is um which is um a
both a descriptive claim and also a sort of call
to action and so it's saying whether you like it
or not tax policies for instance are health
policies because whether or not you have an
extra thousand dollars a year could decide
whether or not you live to the next year um
and on the other hand or at the same time
it is also a call to action saying that we
need to have health in all policies we need to be
advancing health with our policies because if we
do not recognize that our our decisions about
where to put a new highway are going to impact
whether or not people are going to be breathing in
pollution whether they're going to have access to
to travel to work whether they're going
to be displaced by by the building of the
new highway all that impacts health and so we
should start dealing with this and so this is
an idea that's been it's been advanced by
the cdc and um the american public health
association and lots of other people so it's
just sort of out there um so surrounding this
or sort of like underneath this is the the
development of this theory or this um it's a
it's an interdisciplinary movement it's a branch
of interdisciplinary science it's a theoretical
framework it sort of all these things at the same
time and it goes under the name of population
health or population health science sometimes
population health framework and so the person
i mentioned before jeffrey rose came up with that
distinction between the causes of between person
disparities and between population disparities
he was a hugely influential figure but the field
sort of got off the ground initially in the with
this 1994 volume by the canadian institute for
advanced research where they very aptly titled
their this this um this edited volume saying
why are some people healthy and others not and
so the determinants of of of healthy populations
and so why are some people's i think is sort of
the way they mean it healthy and others are not
and so what did it eventually turn into as
described by keys and gaway who sort of wrote like
the sort of like the main sort of um we call it
the textbook on it is um it's a research program
that confronts the structural forces so things
like structural racism for instance that place
individuals at risk that creates distributions
of health and disease unequally across socially
defined groups so think like like for instance
racial groups so it's not committing to the
idea that that um that whiteness for instance is a
biological category it's a socially defined group
but there are differences there are distributions
nonetheless and focuses on embedding biological
pathways within social interactions that
develop across the life course you know from
from from in utero through through death and into
the next generation and across generations so this
is sort of like the theoretical orientation to it
and the thing that's really um that sets it apart
or one of the things that sets it apart is i would
argue would be there's a rooting in uh what's
uh what uh has in in one context always been
called the fallacy of health inequity fatalism
and the way that rose put it in in this 1992
book that became very influential is that
there is no known biological reason why every
population should not be as healthy as the best
so like i was saying at the beginning there
sometimes you're just dealt with dealt a bad hand
by genetics um so there will always be healthier
individuals and sicker individuals if you're born
with a heart defect or a mutation that causes
genetic disease i wrote my dissertation on
genetic diseases um then you're going to be a
disadvantage and we can gradually try to make
progress on counteracting those but you were dealt
a tough hand and so we are we are far away from
from a world in which um in which we can sort
of undo all of those kinds of things that you so
we sort of level that playing field but the the
thing that's radical here is this claim that well
every population is going to have a mix of some
people who are dealt to good and some people were
dealt a bad and some people were born with uh with
congenital heart defects and some weren't some
were born with genetic diseases and and most are
not and so it might always it might be the case
that we'll always have sick individuals but it's
not it doesn't need to be the case that there are
sick zip codes sick neighborhoods sicker countries
cigarette income brackets it doesn't need to be
the case that that's that that's so that that's
going to happen and so so thinking back to that
gradient of your your percentile of income you
know the 40th percentile of income doesn't have to
die sooner than the 55th percentile or even the
41st because each of those populations has it has
people with a varying level of good luck in some
terms um and so so the so so so rose is making a
sort of like a biological claim about the state
of empirical evidence and it's held up over time
but what it really is functioning as sort of like
an ethical provocation is is okay but if there are
these differences between between neighborhoods
like that map i showed of surrounding the
university of virginia well that's the result
of political choices broadly political choices
um that that we don't we didn't have to do them
that way nor do we have to continue doing them
and so this idea that it's it's a it's a fallacy
of a sort of fatalism they're like well that you
have to have sicker populations like no you
don't um uh so i'm borrowing that terminology
from um from the group called a public health
deliberation they just have a new report that
came up um earlier this week actually sort
of like giving that terminology and i like it
so um so with that background set up um here's
what i sort of brought to the table when i was
sort of looking at this stuff so i wrote a book as
was mentioned in the beginning called philosophy
population health because i was really interested
it's like what's going on with this sort of
ideology of population health what are they doing
that's that's different or interesting from what
other people had been doing before or are doing
now um and so i i was sort of looking at it and i
was like well you know i think they i think this
sort this sort of this approach to to health is
i don't have any better ideas um i think this
is a about right i think we should be starting
from these kinds of presumptions i think we should
start with this this this rejection of this of the
assumption of that fatalism i think we should be
taking this approach of thinking about health over
the life course and so i sort of redefine what
what health should mean across the life course
right i made a bunch of sort of like little tweaks
and elaborations and things like that um but what
but what i end the book with which i sort of
wish in hindsight i spent more time doing i've
written a little bit about this afterwards is i
make the claim that that really at the root of
all this is humility that if that's that it is
both descriptively the case so uh so it is the
case that's that that enough that a prac that
practices of being humble are key for this for
this field as a whole about this approach to doing
population health that sort of takes into account
all these different disciplinary approaches to
thinking about how to how to make health better
think of all the different mechanisms of healthier
populations and things like that and is also
ethically and ethically the case that i think
we really need to keep being humble in these
same kinds of ways otherwise this whole this whole
house of cards is going to fall apart so i'll say
what i'll say what that means now and about what
about how this all ties to interdisciplinarity
so i argue again at the end of the book sort of
like the the sort of the concluding lessons is
that we need three kinds of humility to create
a cohesive and equitable culture of health
so the basic idea is that health is too big a
thing it is too complicated it is too multifaceted
for any one person for anyone discipline or any
one sector of society something like government
academia that kind of thing to fully
understand there is no privileged
perspective on health that is superior
to all others i don't think there's any
grounding for any kind of claim that that
like one discipline shall rule them all
and so we need to act humbly toward other sectors
of society that for instance um that academia
healthcare industry agriculture government all
sorts of other sectors need to be brought in as
partners rather than subordinates if we're going
to try to make make health better and we need to
act humbly towards other disciplines it's going
to take many different methods and knowledge
traditions to understand and to advance health
so this is the kind of stuff i'm talking about
so so take something like intersectoral
humility um so this is humility about all
the different different sort of sectors of
society that need to sort of come together
this idea of health across society that
it's going to take to to promote health
um so one example i've been i've been writing
about recently is um is mass incarceration and so
in the united states we've tended to have sort
of like very sort of bracketed and sort of siloed
conversations about how to think about um things
like policing and so policing incarceration it's
pretty well known by this point that they're very
very large um racist health display racist outcome
disparities in terms of incarceration rates
between black americans and white americans
treatment by the police like these
are things that like should not be too
you kind of have to bury your head in the sand to
sort of like to say like no no these these things
don't exist these aren't problems but the problem
is that we we sort of have these conversations in
the realm of of of justice reform of of criminal
law reform and and policing reform and what has
sort of been much much slower to have to sort of
percolate is having these be also conversations
about health because and this is uh from a
report from the robert wood johnson foundation
there are massive health impacts from from mass
incarceration and so we have a system by which we
incarcerate enormous numbers of people and finally
people and people in population health are saying
like well we really need to look at this this
is this is like a really a problem and so these
patterns of mass incarceration create racially
biased burdens on communities where people
get caught in the spiral of discriminatory police
surveillance and so certain neighborhoods get
massive amounts of police police attention
and um and harsher treatments that leads to
the for disparate incarceration rates then a web
of these mutually reinforcing uh harms that happen
even after a person's release from prisons you
have poverty inability to get housing poor mental
and physical health often the loss of voting
rights overall social powerlessness and you sort
of have this spiral of these things all negatively
negatively mutually reinforcing each other and
that's really terrible but these are conversations
that we're not really having in terms of health
at all and so so this is obviously not only a
health problem but if we're going to actually
have any real discussion about about how to how to
deal with the negative impacts of police killing
u.s police killing civilians at massive rates um
higher than than any other any other peer country
or us incarcerating more people than any other
any other peer country then we're we're going to
be missing part of a conversation and so we need
to deal with this as a health problem among other
kinds of problems and so we need to recognize that
we need to start dealing we need to start talking
to to criminal justice reformers if we're going to
to create a healthier united states for instance
these graphs are obviously really messed
up like oh my god oh my god moving on i
can talk about more of that later if you want
um so so getting to the interdisciplinarity so
i i like the idea that this this sort of endeavor
of population health and population health science
or whatever you want to call it i i sort of work
in this area and i'm sort of ambivalent about it
uh in terms of what exactly it should be called
population health something um it's this idea
that it has to be inherently interdisciplinary and
so so for instance i'm uh i'll be co-chairing the
the upcoming conference um this fall which
i encourage you to look at and look into of
the interdisciplinary association for population
health science and so it is the interdisciplinary
association for population health sciences
this is the main population health group
and so um it needs to really really own
this this respect for qualitative data
and quantitative data and ethnographic data all
sorts of different kinds of knowledge traditions
and it gets because the kinds of problems
we're faced with are really really complicated
um and so take for instance um this is a new
article that came out like what day or two ago um
where it was uh this is a headline from
from stat news um like the medical news
site and saying expert sphere us may default to
annual covet boosters without sufficient data
and so i look at that as like okay yeah
like i also want there to be a database
decision to be made about like who
should get a booster every year does
it need to be every year what are the
what are the benefits what are the costs
all that kind of stuff like okay like yeah
i'm i'm down with this idea that we should
sort of like we should think about that but then
thinking but then the the enormous challenge that
we're left with is considering like the enormous
range of expertise that we'll need to synthesize
or at least that we should be synthesizing to
come up with an answer to something like the
question of how how often to recommend covidaxon
boosters and and to whom should we recommend them
so so among other things you have you have t-cell
you know immunologists who felt like really left
out a lot of these conversations because we
really need t-cell data to know about the
durability of immunity and we it's not as easy
to collect that data as some other data and so
we we've sort of been going with the data
we have not the data we want and so like
we we really need to incorporate that t-cell data
about how how are these vaccines performing in
like over time and how much will boost our
health for instance and epidemiologists have
been have been having like a big role in this
but um they they too want more data they want to
they want to be able to synthesize more
of it they sometimes have a hard time
sort of piecing apart the different variables
that that you might might not know know for
instance though there's a problem with um when
comparing the performance of different vaccines
we don't know if there are any sort of
systematic sort of self-selection things
where someone like how do we sort of factor
in that someone might choose to have gotten
the johnson johnson vaccine as opposed to
the modern vaccine the first time around
and how we sort of like incorporate that into
thinking about like how well do these work
uh meanwhile health communicators have been
super frustrated that we sort of that there's
this habit in the united states that including
during the pandemic we tend to design guidelines
to follow the clinical data on efficacy but we
don't necessarily plan around the sort of known
problems like confusion over getting like really
shifting guidelines about these sort of mixed
messages about what vaccines do and wherein and
how you get them and things like that and even
even going even more interdisciplinary
philosophers like mia we sort of worry about who
gets to decide what counts as good enough evidence
that is not an obvious not an obvious answer
um so the best advice i can muster here is
sort of like a general advice is that we should
try to be humble about each of us only
having one piece of a larger puzzle
that nobody sort of has that has the the has
the blueprint for how to do the whole thing
we each only have that one piece of the puzzle
maybe sometimes one people one person's big a
piece is bigger than another but it is it
is always a mere piece of of a larger hole
so all of the so this this intersectoral humility
interdisciplinary humanity they're in some sense
sort of like different instantiations of what's
of what philosophers call epistemic humility
which is basically humility epistemic just means
about about knowledge and evidence and so being
humble about about our our abilities as knowers so
um so i i borrow my sort of my particular concept
of it from from anita ho who's a population
health scholar and also a a feminist bioethicist
and the way she puts it is epistemic humility is
a disposition as well as a commitment it arises
out of professionals knowledge acknowledgement
of the boundary of their expert domain as well
as their fallibility it means a commitment to
make realistic assessment of what one knows
and does not know and to restrict one's
confidence and claims to knowledge only
only to one at one actually knows about his
or her specialized domain in particular it's
a recognition that knowledge creation is an
interdependent and collaborative activity
i'll come back to that in a moment both um she's
looking in the case of like no doctor patient
kind of stuff so both the healthcare provider
and the patient are counting on each other and
investigating a full picture of the patient's
experience and determining the most appropriate
management strategies and so the reason why i like
to i want to sort of press on this especially in
the context of the interdisciplinarity is this
idea that it is a recognition that humility
is a recognition that knowledge creation is
an interdependent and collaborative activity
and so a lot of us in in school i mean i even
went to i went to a math and science sort of like
special magnet school and even in that context i i
was really sort of i was sort of raised into this
idea of of science as being a fundamentally an
individual endeavor that sometimes you work with
other people on and that's that's sort of the
wrong way of thinking about this kind of stuff
i hope i hope i i know it's sort of a mixed bag
about whether science education has improved since
since when i was when i was in elementary school
or whatever this idea that it's an interdependent
and collaborative activity that we need to work
together to sort of to do this kind of stuff
and we need to get used to the idea
of depending on others to sort of work
together to get some knowledge out
of at the end of the tunnel and so
this is actually a bit controversial and sort of
thinking about like how to think about humility
and i think it might be sort of worth sort of
pressing on this a little bit so so this will get
a little more philosophical just for a moment um
hopefully for uh hopefully it'll sort of pay off
so the worry is and it's been it's been
articulated by um by folks like jose medina
who's uh who's another philosopher he worries that
that um that saying humility is a good thing is
actually kind of dangerous yes so this idea that
we should all be epistemically humble he's like
well that's something we should you should sort of
be humble in moderation because if hum if humility
is attentiveness to one's cognitive limitations
and deficits then being too caught up and thinking
about your limitations could be pathological as
to be put or detrimental to your confidence and
character and so we worry about the sort of thing
we're training like scientists or doctors that's
like we don't want we don't want a doctor just
to fold as soon as a patient argues against the
diagnosis or demands a different treatment like
that would be bad and so it's really important we
sort of get really clear on what what it means
to be a humble collaborator or a humble knower
and so if you're thinking only about the
boundaries of of your knowledge or expertise then
um you if we if you only think about your
limitations and not your strengths that could
be a problem and so and so the thing that i where
i disagree with him is he's thinking that humility
is just about about recognizing the boundaries
of your knowledge and not thinking about
uh what's basically the only thing
about what's outside the walls of
your knowledge nothing about what's
inside the walls of your knowledge
and so um so i like i like who's account better
because she says that it's a recognition of
your strengths as well as your weaknesses and
it's and it's not only thinking about your own
strengths but it's also it's also humility is also
reflecting on the person i'm working with on this
what are their abilities what are what are their
limitations and strengths and so we need to sort
of reflect on not only our own limitations
and abilities but also those and others
and so one of the one of the ways this can play
out is this is this idea of um i think humility in
some sense is a way of thinking about sort of like
sharing the lane and so if we're going to get at
big problems we need to learn to share the lane
and so so here's an example of just the police
brutality is our way too according to doctors
thinking about racism as a public health crisis
racism is not only a public health crisis but it
is a health crisis among other kinds of crises
so so for instance in my book i defend the
notion of calling a social problem like a
social problem like gun violence or climate change
um i explicitly talked about both of those um that
those are no they can be criminal justice problems
they could be economic problems but there are they
can be spiritual problems but they're also health
problems um this is really controversial stuff
um i think it's really important um context that
that a lot of this stuff about staying your lane
especially when it comes to when it comes to
health and this is sort of bubbled back up during
during um um covered 19 and things like um the
cdc saying um you can't evict people from their
from their rental apartments because because
it's too dangerous to sort of put people on the
street during a pandemic and then there's like
a big there's a big backlash thing like no no
no that's like overstepping the boundaries of what
counts as as a health issue housing isn't a public
health issue that kind of stuff unfortunately
the supreme court agreed with that position um
and so so some of this actually started starting
coming out um when the night the national rifle
association um started tweeting that doctors need
to stay in their way and stay out of gun control
conversations and then in reply you had a bunch
of doctors tweeting back with the hashtag this
is our lane and then showing pictures of their
gowns after after treating gunshot wounds and so
um so that that's the kind of stuff that's that's
really at stake here when we're talking about how
do we think about sharing the way of like do we
talk about and how do we talk about something like
gun violence or racism or whatever all these sort
of social social equity issues as also health
issues and then who should be contributing to the
health issues and health research things like that
so um also uh it's just because it's it's been
sort of like um a topic has been sort of like
coming out in conversation recently as people have
been talking about solidarity um i think it might
be worth sort of just mentioning here that um that
there there is a relationship between humility
and solidarity especially since solidarity
and sort of how we how we sort of like form
we express solidarity by sort of being with
other peoples like i'm with you in this fight
against cover 19 for instance so it's so it comes
up inside social justice conversations and equity
conversations and so i i think it's it's important
to recognize that this too connects with humility
um and so so inside the way i i've sort
of uh i've written about this a little
bit that um there is an ethical component to
solidarity so like for instance there's uh
um in the in the in the literature on on on
feminist approaches to to bioethics there's this
idea of like relational solidarity which is this
um this idea of like i want to be with somebody
else and i want to be attentive to the power
to power and social and social sort of position
relationships involved in that and so i want to
support the social movement trying to fight for
things like criminal justice reform but i also
want to be really attentive to the way that like
i'm sort of plugging into the system and there
there are sort of power dynamics that that play
and then but there's also an empirical component
to solidarity that i try to press on in
my work sort of as someone who's like
just kind of like enmeshed in this
sort of population health context and i think
it's not really um it's not recognized enough
and so the way the the it sometimes comes
out inside population of literature including
the ottawa charter for health promotion which
was a who statement um and so empirically is sort
of the claim here health is created and lived by
people within the settings of their everyday life
this is sort of one when the sort of the tenets
of population health is that that health happens
in everyday life period um it happens where
they where they learn work play and love
health is created and this is again empirical
by creating by by caring for oneself and others
by being able to take decisions and have control
over one's life circumstances and by ensuring that
the society one lives and creates conditions that
allow the attainment of health by all its members
and so there's this ethical idea of solidarity
that we we need to work together we need to
sort of be with each other and try to do things
like reduce those between zipcode disparities
and there's also an empirical component where
whether or not we can sort of form these
solidarity relationships our health hinges on
those that if we are not taking care of each other
then it it all falls apart and so we either work
together or we're just not going to get anywhere
basically um and so the way that some people try
to cash this out um so like the robert when john
robert wood johnson foundation which is uh
the biggest sort of health oriented um uh um
you know uh um private funding agency in the
united states like they they do health and
they pay they put a lot of money into it
the national academy of medicine has sort
of uh has echoed this kind of language that we
need a culture of health and so um it's it's a
very scary idea that we need to have all these
different aspects of culture all sort of like
intersecting towards are all sort of like working
in collaboration to try to create healthier living
conditions for everyone so we need the biomedical
data research we need we need criminal justice
reform we need food system changes we need housing
reform all this kind of stuff all at the same time
and that is very daunting and very scary but
each of us can sort of put we can can sort of
plug in in a different place and so i'll sort
of uh i'll say a couple words about that then
i'll then i'll stop and have some conversation so
the way that um so um kamara jones the one who who
came up with that um uh that diagram about the
different ways that racism can can um can play
a role in health um she she also came up with this
sort of uh which he call the cliff analogy and so
there are lots of different stages of health and
health outcomes that we can sort of look at and
different places where each of us can play a role
in in sort of like the research world and think
about okay like what's going on here how do we
understand it so if you think about that about
the process of a person standing near the edge
of a cliff falling off the cliff and getting hurt
and so you can look at these issues
at the point of like risk and so like
what is it how close can you get
to the edge before you fall off
how do we know that someone's getting getting too
close to the edge can we warn them before they get
to get too close to the edge what do we do about
that sort of that pivot point between they're fine
they're fine they're fine oh it's looking pretty
precarious and then something bad starts happening
we can work in the in the in
the realm of prediction and so
what's going to happen to this
person after they hit the ground
what kind of care do they need how can
we sort of allocate resources to them
so that we can we can try to help them especially
as effectively and efficiently as possible
we can contribute to the to the
question of like what's it like to be
hurt what are the experiences of a person who
is really really being their suffering what is
it like to be ill how can we understand this
and understand this person and give them the
care and attention they deserve and so that's
another way we can sort of contribute to this
we can obviously work in the area of
care giving and so like once they get
once they get inside the ambulance how do
we treat them best what what do we do for
them once they're in the ambulance and so there
are lots of different disciplinary disciplinary
interdisciplinary ways of contributing to how
do we sort of give them the care they need
and there are also questions of of equity
itself and so we can ask questions about
differences in quality of care why do some
people get into the nice ambulance and other
people get into the ambulance that's not so good
um we have differences in access to care and so
or even things like some people have a a
metaphorical fence that protects them from
falling off the edge and other people they're
always sort of living they're always sort of uh
there's nothing sort of there's no net or
fence to sort of protect them from falling off
some people also have nets to sort of catch them
on the way down the u.s is a sort of infamous in
the international sphere for basically not having
much of a social safety net to speak of we have
very limited housing support or whether food
security support things like that like you are
largely on your own united states if things go
wrong and they're also differences in exposures
and opportunities and so some populations are
always living near the edge that you're always one
one negative thing uh one negative impact
away from sort of like having everything
sort of spiral out of control and other
people have lots of buffer to protect them
they have lots of room to roam around and so
in the in the context of interdisciplinarity
there are lots of different ways each of us can
sort of can can help you can sort of study this
stuff per se you can sort of like be one of the
ones like i'm going to look at this equity kind
of issues we can also have an equity-minded lens
towards looking at things like caregiving or what
it's like to be ill and so we each have a role
we can play so there's a lot of work to be done
but the point is that we'll need humility to
make the to make any headway on the big sort
of rebuilding challenges to make a better world
and so we need to listen to more kinds of voices
than what we're maybe used to that it's very hard
to sometimes have conversations with people who
have very different uh perspectives whether
it's a disciplinary perspective or just um
a different perspective because of
the of the kind of life they've lived
uh we need to question our convictions about
our knowledge we need to we need to think about
what our strengths and limitations and also
the strengths and limitations of others
and most of all we need to be collaborative
in order to rebuild this kind of world because
um if knowledge really is a collaborative activity
and i really do believe that that science and all
sorts of and and applied science it's a team sport
we need to start acting that way and not be so not
be so obsessed with like who gets to control this
kind of thing and who's going to be the who has
the most important control contribution to this
project that kind of stuff we need to act with
some more humility so i'll stop there and move to
a conversation and hear some very tiny references
john thank you so much that was really wonderful
i mean you really drove home the fact that
health is just not an isolated thing it's like so
dimensional and there's so many different aspects
to it one of our participants here loved the way
that you differentiated between causes of cases
and causes of incidents oh yeah yeah jeffrey rose
is awesome so tell us a little bit more about that
why have you adopted that what was your rationale
for kind of like uh stressing that it sounds like
it made a real impact yeah it made an impact on
me um so i guess i can sort of partially explain
this autobiographically so i like a lot of people
sort of work in sort of like philosophy and ethics
and stuff like that of science and technology i
i was sort of initially drawn to things like um
genetic testing and advanced genetic technologies
and things like that and i think those are those
are perfectly interesting and worthy endeavors
um but i felt like the kind of things i was
interested in were essentially like it sort
of dawned on me one day like i'm sort of like
i've been spending all my time looking at
the technologies of the one percent or like
the would be technologies of the one percent
and i felt like it wasn't where the action is
is the way i was starting to think of it and
so i was thinking about okay like i'm doing
things looking at like new novel technologies
and the possibilities of gene therapy for
for for different health conditions
and even something like sickle cell
anemia which is uh which is uh it finishes a
higher burden of disease on black americans
than white americans although it's not only
black americans and that's a misconception
um and i was i was sort of looking at that
like well but the the disparities between the
health of black americans and white americans or
between hispanic americans and other populations
all these other different different sort of
disparities those aren't because of genetics
and so i felt sort of like like i was sort of
not following my interests in some sense because
i got i wanted to get at those disparities and
there are these disparities between individual
people and sometimes they're they're they are
sort of partially tracking the genetic things
but i felt like i was only looking at sort of like
the rounding errors um and i wasn't sort of going
where the action is and so like why are why what
are the causes of disparities between populations
why are the where why are there these
these six zip codes and neighborhoods
and countries even like the united states and so
that that's what sort of drew me in it's like okay
because it's gonna be just different stuff it's
gonna be different kinds of causes and so it's
not that not to say that the sickle cell and
media research isn't important like it really
is and then it's and that it's not relevant to
to racial health equity like yeah we should be
investing in that because that is a problem
and it's it's uh it predominantly impacts a a
population that's been it's been marginalized
by us society but that but that's not gonna
that's not gonna deal with most of the problem
of the vast life expectancy disparities and
heart disease outcome disparities and cancer
outcome disparities things like that i loved how
you discussed humility and its importance for us
to come together as a multi-disciplinary science
to be able to solve a lot of these problems and
just basically hear each other out and take into
account all of the different voices which
contribute to this multi-dimensional health
notion that you described i'm also keenly aware
of the hubris which seems to exist in our business
where indeed often a very small but very very
loud minority of people who are not so humility
not so humble and have that much humility and
in fact it's kind of their way or the highway
and often that's what happens i'm curious of
that contrast and what that may mean to you
what it may mean in the philosophy of
you know the population health sciences
yeah i um that that too frustrates me it also
happens within my field of philosophers are sort
of known for being like exceptionally arrogant as
a as a whole um or on average uh it's uh it's a
it could be rather infuriating um but you see you
have your similar kinds of complaints about like
all sorts of different different sort of like uh
disciplinary groups or whatever or subsets thereof
um for me it's been like it's obviously annoying
and rude when someone does that kind of thing when
someone's when someone is hubristic or a bully
or tries to run the show it's it's sort of easy
to sort of to go to the sort of the low-hanging
fruit just say like well you shouldn't do that
because it's sort of bad form or it's not good
collaborative it's not a good collaborative
activity to sort of to do that kind of thing
or insist that you that you be the pi for no
particular reason that kind of stuff um and
like yes that is the case that like um but i
i sort of i found it interesting for myself
to sort of to try to lay out sort of like a
a sort of like a an additional few wares of sort
of like of rationale and sort of um lowercase p
philosophy about like not only is it sort of bad
form to to be hubristic like that to be that uh
to be that that that um that kind of person but
that it's it's also fundamentally fundamentally
counterproductive to anything inside the inside
the study of health that it is impossible to get
an understanding of health without sort of working
together and to recognizing that there are sort of
um an infinite number of perspectives on this sort
of like this multi-faceted whole of what health is
and so it's not only that you that you're sort of
being rude but that you're that what you're doing
is fundamentally in conflict with our ability to
actually accomplish anything in this area and so
so you not only are you are you sort of being a
jerk you're also being you're setting us up for
failure there's uh enormous opportunities here for
people who are working in data science artificial
intelligence as they are thinking about how to
construct intelligent systems which can help
guide health making decisions about how to
spread the wealth of health resources around
what are some things that you think they
should know as they're thinking about that
that touch on population health uh health
equity and other forms of fairness if you
will i mean just based on the the things i
i'm not an expert particularly in ai and and
intelligence systems and things like that
but i i know some of the literature on it and
you you see fairly sort of like more sophisticated
or more more sort of technologically sophisticated
versions of older problems that when the group
of people that are developing or testing a system
have a certain perspective they're not
necessarily going unless they make it a
point to seek out other perspectives they might
sort of build their biases into the system
and so what counts as success or what kinds of
inputs do we put into it and so whether it's
uh um camera systems that aren't able to track
faces that are that that are that are darker
than the people who develop them like that's
that's something that that's happened there's
even been satires about exactly that problem
the cameras that can't recognize black faces
um or whether it's um it's a sort of uh this
tendency to think that okay well my job as a
as a data scientist is just sort of to build the
thing or i'm a data engineer and so i'm going
to i'm going to build the thing and it's it's
someone else's job to deal with the problem of
okay but like who's it going to impact and how
is it going to impact them and so that sort of
hands off approach like well i'm just in my silo
over here and i make things and if it's going to
be used by a health insurance company to to try to
find people to to take away their their coverage
then that's that's their problem or if it's it's
going to be used as a means for trying to do more
sophisticated policing or something like that
that it's that's not my job or something like
that and so recognizing the interconnectedness of
what we're doing and um recognizing that they're
going to be they're going to be disparate
impacts on different populations when you
create a new technology and being making it a
point to try to find out like okay how is this
going to negatively how is this going to impact
people from different socioeconomic groups from
different from different racial groups are are
there are there anticipatable sometimes there are
unanticipated ones but are there anticipatable
problems that we should be looking for now
john thank you so much for a wonderful
presentation for this fantastic discussion we so
appreciate it uh this has been really an education
thank you so much um thank you to everybody who
joined us everyone have a wonderful weekend and uh
for those of our participants we will see you all
next week thanks again sean we really appreciate
it thank you very much and uh feel free to
contact me i'm easy to find at the center for
bioethics and social justice in michigan state